[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Katja Stresow ist auch wieder
dabei mit neuen Medaillen in Planitzer
schönen guten Abend und das sind die
Themen von heute
ein Jahr nach der Zeitenwende bei der
Bundeswehr geht die Modernisierung nur
schleppend voran
Bootsunglück vor Süditalien mindestens
59 geflüchtete ertrinken in stürmischer
See
und WM-Erfolg in der mix-staffel die
Nordischen Kombinierer freuen sich über
Silber
kurz nach Kriegsbeginn kündigte der
Bundeskanzler eine Zeitenwende an plus
100 Milliarden Euro um die Bundeswehr
wieder fit zu machen ein Jahr ist das
morgen her aber für die Soldaten habe
sich noch nichts spürbar verbessert sagt
der Verbandschef der Bundeswehr Wüstner
er fordert mehr Tempo wie schleppen die
Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr läuft zeigen
diese Zahlen von den angekündigten 100
Milliarden sind bislang erst 10 in neues
Material geflossen 30 so heißt es jetzt
sollen es bis Jahresende sein etwa für
soldatenkleidung die Bewaffnung von
Drohnen oder den Tarnkappenbomber F35
mit diesen Ausgaben bleibt Deutschland
aber immer noch deutlich unter seinen
Zusagen an die NATO Frank Buchwald
Boris Pistorius hat sorgen und das liegt
am Geld viel davon 100 Milliarden nur
für die Bundeswehr in der Truppe aber
kommt bisher nichts an nun erhöht der
Minister des Marsch Tempo bis Ende des
Jahres will er 30 Milliarden investieren
Pistorius am Abend im Bericht aus Berlin
wir leisten bereits gehöriges und meine
Absicht ist dass wir zunächst die ganzen
internen Regeln die es gibt
prozessrichtlinien und anderes die wir
uns selber als Ministerium in den
letzten 30 Jahren auferlegt haben dass
wir die abwerfen um schneller agieren zu
können da muss ich nicht mal an Gesetze
ran und das ist jetzt der erste Schritt
und der wird schon für Beschleunigung
sorgen tatsächlich sind viele Fahrzeuge
der Bundeswehr nicht einsatzfähig
ähnliches gilt für Flugzeuge der
Luftwaffe und für Schiffe Deutschland
kaum abwehrbereit ja die Situation vor
diesem russischen barbarischen
Angriffskrieg war schon prekär in der
Bundeswehr und sie ist bisher kein
Deutsch besser geworden das hängt
natürlich mit den Abgaben an die Ukraine
zusammen berechtigt der Weise aber es
fließt noch zu wenig nach und es wird
noch nicht mal das nachbestellt was wir
abge gegeben haben deshalb kann Berlin
auch seine Verpflichtungen in der NATO
kaum erfüllen brandgefährlich kritisiert
die Opposition und fordert neben den 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen deutlich mehr
Geld für den Verteidigungshaushalt
was ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass dieses
Russland auch die NATO bedroht und
angreift deswegen muss die Bundeswehr
jetzt dringend wieder verteidigungsfähig
werden und dazu sind 10 Milliarden pro
Jahr das Minimum was erforderlich ist
zusätzliche Milliarden in einem ohnehin
schon knappen Haushalt das bedeutet mehr
Schulden oder mehr sparen beides löst in
der Koalition gewöhnlich Streit aus noch
eine Sorge mehr für den Minister
Deutschland sucht dringend Fachkräfte im
vergangenen Jahr kamen bis zu 3000 aus
Indien vor allem IT-Leute das sollen
viel mehr werden dafür warb der
Bundeskanzler auf seiner Reise in Indien
das bald größte Land der Welt mit der
Zeit 1,4 Milliarden Einwohner und rasant
wachsender Wirtschaft wird nicht nur für
Deutschland immer wichtiger Normen
Odenthal
der Zauber Indiens pralldorf
hanseatische Gelassenheit bei dieser
Reise geht es nun mal darum aus
unterschiedlichen Welten gemeinsame
Interessen herauszufiltern
nirgends geht das leichter als in der
Wirtschaft mit dem automatischen
Batteriewechsel in der E-Mobilität zeigt
diese Firma Innovationen und
Investitionen aus beiden Ländern können
sich ergänzen Partnerschaften
funktionieren wenn beide Seiten
profitieren und Indien hat was
Deutschland fehlt massenhaft junge Leute
mit Potential Deutschland ist ein Landes
große Wertschätzung genießt hier in
Indien und deshalb bin ich ganz sicher
dass viele die Möglichkeiten nutzen
werden und nutzen wollen als Fachkräfte
in Deutschland tätig zu sein wir
brauchen das in allen Bereichen
Einwanderung erleichtern Bürokratie
abbauen der Kanzler verspricht sich ins
Zeug zu legen Indien tut das bereits und
er arbeitet sich eine beeindruckende
Bilanz 15% des globalen Wachstums werden
in diesem Jahr hier erwirtschaftet
prognostizieren Experten noch verhandelt
Deutschland aus einer Position der
Stärke doch Indien wird vorbei ziehen
eher früher als später Signal dieser
Kanzler Reise die Chance zu guten
Bedingungen ins Geschäft zu kommen ist
jetzt
im Nahen Osten reiste die Gewalt nicht
ab heute tagten in Jordanien hochrangige
Vertreter aus Israel und den
Palästinenser Gebieten beide
seitenvereinbarten auf eine Deeskalation
hinarbeiten zu wollen überschattet wurde
das Treffen von einem mutmaßlich
palästinensischen Anschlag
investjordanland dabei wurden zwei
israelische Siedler in ihrem Wagen
erschossen seit Monaten kommt es in dem
von Israel besetzten Palästinenser
Gebiet zu gewaltsamen Zusammenstößen
für mindestens 59 Menschen wurde das
Mittelmeer heute erneut zur Todesfalle
bei schwerer See verunglückte ein Boot
mit Flüchtlingen kurz vor Erreichen des
rettenden Ufers etwa 80 Personen konnte
die Küstenwache retten die Tragödie
ereignete sich in Kalabrien in der
Provinz Crotone Annette hilsenbeck
berichtet
die Trümmer des verunglückten Bootes
angeschwemmt am Strand des Ortes qutro
die Küstenwache und Feuerwehrleute sind
hier im Einsatz sie bergen die die das
Unglück nicht überlebt haben es werden
immer mehr
ich habe Dinge gesehen die zu
schrecklich sind Kinder die geborgen
werden mussten es sind viele Kinder man
weiß noch nicht wie viele
inzwischen 12 Kinder sollen unter den
Opfern sein von den Überlebenden kommen
20 ins Krankenhaus die anderen werden in
ein Flüchtlingscamp gebracht laut
offiziellen Angaben stammen sie unter
anderem aus Afghanistan und Pakistan das
Boot soll vor etwa vier Tagen im
türkischen Izmir gestartet sein in der
Nacht hatte die eu-küstenwache
frontextes gesichtet stürmisches Wetter
verhinderte eine Rettung am Nachmittag
besuchte Italiens Innenminister piante
Dosi den Unglücksort er hatte zuvor von
einer Tragödie gesprochen es sei
notwendig die irregulären
einwanderungsketten zu bekämpfen
Italiens Rechte Regierung fährt einen
rigiden migrationskurs
Papst franziskus zeigte sich heute auf
dem Petersplatz tief betroffen vom
Unglück ich bete für jeden von ihnen für
die vermissten und für jene die überlebt
haben ich danke denen die Hilfe gebracht
haben und denen die sie aufnehmen
[Musik]
die Suche geht weiter nach dem
Bootsunglück werden noch weitere Opfer
vermutet
die EU schickt weitere Hilfe in das vom
Erdbeben Betroffene Syrien mit einer
sogenannten humanitären Luftbrücke in
Damaskus landeten heute die ersten
beiden Flugzeuge mit dringend benötigten
Gütern an Bord wie winterfeste Zelte
Ausrüstung für Unterkünfte und
Heizgeräte insgesamt sollen so rund 420
Tonnen Hilfsgüter ins Land kommen etwa
die Hälfte stammt aus eigenen
Lagerbeständen
Rettungsmission im All eine unbemannte
sajus-kapsel hat an die Internationale
Raumstation ISS angedockt sie ersetzt
dort eine Raumfähre die ein Leck hat an
Bord hat sie zudem medizinische Geräte
und Ausrüstung im September soll die
Kapsel zwei Russen und einen Amerikaner
zurück zur Erde bringen die drei sitzen
derzeit auf der ISS fest
zurück auf die Erde zur Berlinale dort
wurden gestern Abend die Bären verliehen
als beste Hauptdarstellerin zeichnete
die Jury die spanische
Nachwuchsschauspielerin Sophia otardo
aus die neunjährige spielt ein Kind auf
der Suche nach seiner geschlechtlichen
Identität Otero ist damit die jüngste
Gewinnerin der Festival Geschichte den
Großen Preis der Jury gewann der
deutsche Film roter Himmel von Regisseur
Christian Petzold
und auch heute gab es wieder Medaillen
bei der Nordischen Ski-WM in Planica
Slowenien das Ergebnis beim Skispringen
steht noch raus sie springen noch aber
in der Nordischen Kombination da freute
sich der Deutsche Skiverband im ersten
mix-team-wettbewerb der WM Geschichte
mit Vincent Geiger Jenny Nowak Natalie
Armbruster und Julian Schmidt über Platz
das Empfangskomitee für Schlussläufer
Julian Schmidt war bester Laune denn
mehr als dieser zweite Platz war bei der
WM Premiere nicht zu erwarten nach dem
Sprung von Natalie Armbruster auf 91
Meter liegt Deutschland zunächst auf
Platz 3 eine gute Ausgangsposition für
Vinzenz Geiger der dann hinter Norwegen
und Japan auf Medaillenjagd in der Loipe
geht denn Sieg der übermächtigen
Norweger mit Schlussläufer ja Magnus
Riva kann das deutsche Quartet nicht
verhindern aber Julian Schmied bringt
ungefährdet Platz zwei vor Österreich
ins Ziel
in der Fußball-Bundesliga endete das
erste Sonntagsspiel Unentschieden mit
jeweils einem Tor für Freiburg und
Leverkusen und im Spitzenspiel zwischen
Bayern München und Union Berlin steht es
gut zehn Minuten vor Schluss 13:0 für
den Rekordmeister ja noch mal zurück zum
Springen einer kann das auch nämlich
amor duplantis Stabhochspringer aus
Schweden er hat mal wieder einen
Weltrekord aufgestellt bei einem
einladungswettkampf in clermont-ferrero
Frankreich übertragen die plantes in
seinem dritten Versuch sechs Meter 22 er
verbesserte damit seine eigene Bestmarke
um einen Zentimeter es war der insgesamt
6 Weltrekord für den 23-Jährigen
im Volleyball haben die Frauen des SCC
Schwerin das Pokalfinale gewonnen durch
einen 3:1-erfolg gegen den SC Potsdam
und bei den Männern holten die Berlin
Volleys hier links im Bild zum sechsten
Mal den deutschen Pokal im Finale setzen
Sie sich setzen sich die Berliner gegen
die powervolleys aus Düren ebenfalls mit
drei zu eins durch
und sie springen immer noch aber nichts
machen
das bringt morgen einige Schneeschauer
in den östlichen Mittelgebirgen und am
Alpenrand sonst scheint auf die Sonne
die Temperaturen erreichen maximal minus
ein bis plus 8 Grad mit teils
östlichen Richtungen
Dunja Hayali begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn im heute-journal hier übernimmt
morgen Jana pareigis wir sagen danke und
tschüss und empfehlen jetzt Berlin
direkt mit Chuck unterlabani